check out this video This is Wild this
is from Boston Logan Airport and they
are housing illegals take a
look that's Boston Logan Airport Boston
Logan Airport by the way what was it two
of the planes from 9/11 I believe
originated at Boston Logan Airport who
are these people what are the security
measures over there is that a hotel is
that a Migrant Center remember when we
showed you months and months ago we
probably on this show showed it to you I
don't know six eight months ago what was
going on at the Texas El Paso Airport
right and that's thought of as a Border
Town so who cares what's going on down
there you ship a couple of those people
up to Martha Vineyard and then all hell
breaks loose those liberals don't have
to live on their little island with
people of another color that's very
scary for them Barack Obama's got his 30
Acres on the w he's freaking out over
climate change don't put any extra
pressure on him so you understand this
these people come in through the
southern border and then in a in a wise
move uh the governors of some of these
states Arizona Texas even Florida have
just decided to ship these people out
sorry we're not Sanctuary States we're
not Sanctuary cities you are we know
this is happening in Chicago uh O'Hare
up north uh it's happening as we just
showed you in Boston and uh who are
these people well here's a little video
of just some of the recent people
wandering into the United
States they let him through look at this
look at this look at
this to give all these women and
children what is going on here where are
the women where are the children can we
can we throw back to that find me a
woman or a child here find me a woman or
a child all these guys 18 19 20 25 they
look like they're maybe not even in
their 30s where are the women do you see
one woman
you see one I mean it's absolutely
insane